[Music]
dale is in boise hi dale welcome to the
ramsay show
yeah thank you for having me on sure
what's up
um so i got a question for you i mean we
pretty much have solid you know all the
baby steps
owned several pieces of property free
and clear pretty much dumped all our
money into
paying everything off
but here later in life
we decided to build a rv park because it
seems to be kind of the trend
and um
we have an sba loan but
we can't pay the loan off as fast as we
would like to because there's a really
hefty
repayment penalty so it's like well what
do we do
you know with the extra money that that
we can't
you know run like we usually do
you know keep keeping it you know
everything paid off low profile i mean
we've had the same cars that we've had
for 25 years we don't just go what's the
balance on the sba loan
uh 1.8 million
ouch that's goodness
and it has a prepayment penalty on a two
million dollar loan
that's really unusual okay
10 years it's uh
2.38 interest
fixed for 20-year amortization but we
can't pay it off for 10
10 years
and uh and how many years on the 10 how
long ago did you do this mess
we just we just flipped from the
construction
takeout to the permanent finance team
good lord
have you done the math on the difference
between the prepayment penalty and the
interest you would save by paying it off
early
it's um 25
of the loan
so it's substantial
you know you're looking at you know 425
thousand dollar prepayment totally
at what point in the process did you not
stop and go this is a dumb butt idea
well the the cash flow makes it
worthwhile
of doing but hypothetically
unless nobody comes to an rv park
because there's a pandemic and then you
go bankrupt
and you took out a prepayment penalty of
25
and willingly knowingly signed up for
that
wow dude government
at its finest i mean that's what that no
no no
the government didn't have a gun to your
head you signed the paper the the lender
can make up whatever wacko terms they
want to you have you have feet to walk
away and you're supposed to use them man
oh my god all right so do you have any
money
uh very little cash on hand right now
most of all of our uh xbas money has
went into the
construction because the prices of
everything have went up 200 to 300
percent hold on hold on it's not hold on
it's not because of the prices it's
because you chose to spend it
yeah
your whole orientation is everybody did
this to you
yeah
like it was out of your control you know
like you didn't have a choice to do all
this so all right you've done it now i'm
gonna quit beating on you so here's the
deal
uh what you've got to do is you need to
save up 1.8 million dollars as fast as
you can and set it in an investment to
the side
so that when the 10-year clock goes
ding-ding you write a check
and
you need you need a tremendous amount of
liquidity no you don't need to pour
anything else into this
freaking rv park
no
uh you're already deep in it so what you
need to do is take any money you can
find from anywhere and begin an
investment pool on the side to pay this
loan off the day it hits
the um
the the date gets down small enough that
you can that you want to bite the bullet
on the prepayment penalty or the day it
hits the 10-year mark and you write that
check so you need a mutual fund that the
target on it is i want to put 1.8
million dollars in
and you better hope that gas doesn't get
up to four dollars and 50 cents a bear i
mean a gallon again people quit
taking their rvs out as much as they
have the last few years yeah yeah again
dang man that's heartbreaking you're
gonna be stuck in your old cars for a
season man you put yourself in big rates
interest rates go up you know what
happens to rv sales
i stop and when gas prices go up people
quit toting around the country and so
man
yeah
i'm just a barrel we're just barely good
news today but um anyway but yeah that's
something good happened to you call
today too yeah
oh so yeah the answer to your question
is no you don't put money back into the
business yes you pile money on the side
as fast as you can politics highest you
can pilot so you've got liquidity
because you have a bigger mess on your
hands than you perceive
and that's why we're both kind of we
have both have both of us john and i
have a little panic in our voice that
you are not experiencing in your body
and when that does hit your body someday
i want you to have a big pile of money
because it's coming yeah it's take
ownership of your choices brother take
ownership